>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington DC.
>> Kenneth Nyirady: This event is
sponsored by the European division
which is one of four area
study divisions in the library.
We are responsible for recommending
from and providing reference
for most of the countries of Europe
except Great Britain and Ireland
which is covered by the main
reading room, Spain and Portugal
which is covered by the Hispanic
division, and the European part
of Turkey which is covered by the
Africa and Middle Eastern division.
Our collection of Hungarica is
the largest outside of Hungary
and numbers about a quarter of a
million volumes, 250,000 volumes
of Hungarian or Hungary-related
material.
If you'd like to know more, you can
go to the European division website
which is two clicks
off of the homepage.
Go to Researchers and then
the European division.
Andras Visky was born in
Targu-Mures, [Inaudible], Romania.
He is a poet, playwright, and
essayist, and resident dramaturg
at Cluj-Napoca Hungarian Theater in
Romania where he holds the position
of Associate Artistic Director.
He holds a Doctorate of
Liberal Arts from the University
of Theater and Film in Budapest.
And since 1994, his lecture
at the [Inaudible] University
in [Inaudible] in the Department
of Theater and Television.
He is one of the cofounders and
the former Executive Director
of [Inaudible] Publishing.
His plays have been
staged in various countries
of Europe and the United States.
His work will now reach an
English-speaking audience
with his latest book,
"Barrack Dramaturgy," published
by Intellect Books and distributed
by the University of Chicago Press.
It contains an anthology of
his well-known plays as well
as a critical analysis of his
theory of considering the theater
as a space for exploring feelings
of cultural and personal captivity.
This collection makes use of
scripts and director's notes as well
as interviews and creative
teams behind the productions
and reveals an insider's view
of Mr. Visky's artistic vision.
And we have a small display of
his books outside all of this room
that you can view as you leave.
It is my pleasure to introduce
to you Dr. Andras Visky.
[ Applause ]
>> Andras Visky: Thank
you very much.
Thanks for coming.
Thank you, Ken, Erica, Natalia.
I plan today to speak
mostly about this book,
about this "Barrack
Dramaturgy," which was created
by me many, many years ago.
So I would like to begin
by telling you that for me,
the theater is a tool
for creating tools.
I used to say that the
theater is not a place
for me for entertainment.
It's a place for serious gatherings.
That doesn't mean that I don't
like when my audience would
laugh during the show,
but I think that this
is not the purpose.
First of all, let's see
how I got to this idea
of considering the theater
a real event for everybody
who takes part in the show.
I never divide the space of the
theater into the space of the show
and the space of the audience.
I think that these two are emerging
to get our penetrating
into each other.
My first memory as a child was
when I was one-year-old,
that I'm a prisoner.
After '56 -- I think that
most of you are familiar
with the Hungarian
revolution in '56.
In Romania more than
30,000 potential opposers
of the regime were
sentenced in prison.
My father was sentenced
for 22 years.
So I don't have even
a personal memory
of my father before
his imprisonment.
Then we were removed
in a prison camp.
My mother, an Austrian, grown
up in Budapest, Hungary,
not knowing one word
in Romanian language,
and we spent more than four years.
My father served almost
7 years in the prison.
We didn't know about each other.
We didn't know about him, where
he was, is he alive or not.
We were totally separated.
I am the seventh in my family, so
my mother with seven very active
and very hungry kids, ended
up in this prison camp
which had become later
on a very famous village
for the Romanian intelligentsia,
because very interesting
people were sentenced together
with us to live there.
This is the family here.
That man, [Inaudible],
was a student.
He was a student during
the Hungarian revolution.
He was a student in
Timisoara and now he is a page
of the Romanian history
because he was the one
who formulated the [inaudible] of
the Romanian students influenced
by the Hungarian revolution
in Romania.
So after prison, he was sentenced
again, not to go home but to stay
in this prison camp which
is probably familiar to you
because of the novels
of Solzhenitsyn
or Shalam Wolf [phonetic], right?
So you can see how a
barrack would look.
It's behind us.
I am down there, the fairly
depressed youngest child.
Here is a famous photo.
It is the winter in our prison camp.
The printers were unbelievably
strong.
There is a wind which is called
[inaudible] coming from Russia
and brings a lot of snow.
For instance, I remember when the
snow covered up totally our barrack,
but it happened very often during
the - It was a plain field,
no trees, only these barracks,
and we got covered up
totally by the snow.
I thought for years that this was
only the image of my imagination.
And then I found from photography
how the people are working
on their roof.
It's like a Chagall painting.
The people floating
above their homes
and being a part of a mythology.
So what am speaking about
now is that, for me,
it's hardly separable -- the
reality from the mythology.
I think that the imagination--
sometimes it's a much
stronger reality
than the reality, which
is hiding from us.
It's very hard to grasp the reality.
Actually, this is the main
reason we are doing theater,
not to create an illusion but to
create a counter reality in order
to understand better
our own reality.
The man there -- I
really love this picture.
His name is Paul Goma, a
famous Romanian author who,
after the prison, came to our camp.
Now, this is a map of the camp, done
by that student who is behind us
in the camp, a very famous map.
I have the original one but there
is a version in a museum in Romania,
the Museum of the Communist
Terror in Romania in [Inaudible].
You can find our name also there.
Let me show it to you.
[ Laughter ]
This is the family Visky.
But there are other
very famous names also.
For instance, in the same
village lived the wife
of the former prime minister
of Romania, Maria Antonescu.
I remember her very well.
Former members of government,
and you won't believe probably
that I don't know how
but I'm researching now,
I'm working on a novel
of the village.
It lands there a piano
also, in this village.
Probably it's like a part of
this theatricality of the place,
or I was together there with
the first Romanian woman pilot,
Nadia Russo [phonetic], a
very well-known name now.
So let's come back to the cover.
So I think that this experience of
being a prisoner first for myself,
than being released
during the dictatorship,
so it was a semi-freedom
than afterwards, until '89 --
brought me to this idea that the
captivity is a universal experience
of the humanity.
I have a definition
of the captivity.
Now, be attentive.
My definition of captivity is
that captivity is a state of being
in which we are dislocated
from our bodies.
So we are dislocated
What does it mean?
That the prisoner is
never present in himself.
He is not there.
He is always [inaudible].
So a prisoner always creates
his or her own double,
like [Inaudible] would
say, great French artist.
I relate to that double which
is an expression of freedom
for me but I am a prisoner.
So what is the theatrical
space for me?
It's a where we freely shoot
ourselves in order to be set free
by the event, what happens there.
What does it mean to set free?
Don't think about something big.
A special understanding of yourself.
A new understanding your identity
or your own personal story
or regarding your relationships,
etc. etc. So I think
that the 20th century created
this kind of universal aspect
of the human being to create huge
factories to exterminate people.
For instance, gulag --
What does it mean, gulag?
Gulag is an acronym which means
that chief quarter of camps --
that would be Russian meaning
of this -- corrective camps.
This is a euphemism
for extermination camp,
because when someone wants to
correct you in a prison, I mean,
we were political prisoners, right?
We were there because of our
convictions about freedom,
about the rights of a person.
Then a corrective camp means
extermination camp, right?
But at the same time, don't
think that for a child
to be a prisoner in
a gulag camp was sad.
I tried to be happy.
My older siblings, they kept
teaching me to recognize my father
on small black and white photos.
And I couldn't recognize him all the
time and that's sort of a big trauma
for me, how to recognize
your father.
That's not possible.
So my poetry, my writings
are focused on this idea
of being dislocated and we
are addicted to freedom.
That would be probably the
definition of a human being.
So the lack of freedom
creates big traumas for us.
If we shut in ourselves
in a theater,
that means that there
is no hierarchy
between actors and audience.
So I don't write stories
for the stage.
I try to write snapshots with
big open spaces and empty spaces
in order to offer for the
audience to enter in the story,
to offer for them to recognize
themselves in the play.
So what happens in a cell?
The freedom is highly fictionalized.
The space is always tight.
If you move, you bump into somebody.
If you move, you create a conflict.
So the level of the story
within a cell should be much,
much higher than in normal life.
And what happens in a cell?
Obsessive rituals which
you cannot control.
You have to follow them.
These are not happy rituals but
these rituals help you to survive.
So I show to you how
the barrack looked like.
I remember, for instance, a group
of Franciscan monks who served
in the prison, I don't
know, more than 10 years,
than they were removed to our camp.
And one of them, he made --
actually, it was a Romanian man --
he was a priest actually.
He made a small chapel
in his barrack.
And I remember going there in
this chapel, entering this chapel
and the lights that dim space and
watching these people like singing
and elevating their souls.
And I remember very well one
man who was the main singer.
When he came out when the service
ended, he always kissed the ground.
And that was, for me,
not understandable.
How would you kiss the
ground of your detention?
What is this space about?
I think that's why I
ended up in the theater,
because of this theatricality
of the loneliness.
And I remember, once
everybody left the barrack
and I stayed there and
I kissed the ground.
And I feel even today, the
ground, it was very cold.
It was not nice at all.
And then again, I couldn't
understand why.
What's that now?
So I discovered reality.
I discovered an inner reality which
is as bleak as the outer reality.
You can disappear in
this inner reality also.
So I began to write plays.
That was my main focus, to
follow different situations
of imprisonment, dependencies, which
is in the same way an imprisonment.
So let me show it to you -- images.
This is a play which was produced in
Chicago in two different versions,
and it's called "Juliet."
It's not called "Romeo and
Juliet," only "Juliet."
Because in my play,
Romeo is in prison,
and Juliet, my mother, is with us.
So it's a re-writing of Shakespeare
in a way, because my mother went
to a vast experience in the camp.
They take her away from us and we
were expecting to remain alone,
which was one of the most
tragic outcomes for the children
in all kinds of dictatorships,
I think,
because they put you in
different orphanages.
So you get cut off from
every personal relationship,
from everybody.
And they have taken my mother.
But after a few days,
she came back to us.
So I wrote a play about the
disappearance of my mother
and the resurrection of my mother.
How Juliet is resurrecting in
not the best moment in her grave.
Her name is Julia --
the name of my mother.
So that's why it's
Juliet in the play.
This is another one,
a part of a trilogy.
I will speak more about
this a little bit.
It's called "Born for Never."
Ten actors are on the
stage but only one.
But only one -- this one in
this solitary confinement
who is the author - only
he is real on the stage.
Everybody's coming out
from his imagination.
You can see the space.
It's like a skin, but the writing,
it's not readable on that skin.
So what the performance is doing
reveals the story of these people,
reveals this writing
during the show.
I'm happy with this.
It went very well at
the Festival d'Avignon,
toured in Europe and
many, many places.
I tried to combine the
stories of the Holocaust
with the stories of the gulag.
Because in the prison, one of
my father's cellmates was a man,
a Holocaust survivor, with
then was sentenced again.
So he was a professional prisoner.
And I dedicated to him
this writing actually.
And when he went in this cell,
for instance to talk to my father,
he always touched the bed, like
the mezuzah, to enter the space.
And that story for
me was unbelievable.
This is the way to transform a cell
in your private freedom in order
to follow that ritual, which
brings you back in time
and brings you back
in a different space.
This is the way to deny the cell.
And I was very glad
to hear this story
so I wrote a play dedicated to him.
In this image, you can
see I created a character.
He is a handicapped man, and
everybody has to carry him around.
And interesting, it creates a
sort of humor in the piece also
because they tend to forget him.
And then they are going
back and they are holding
and they are bringing with them.
Because I saw many people in
the prison camp, very old people
for instance, who could
not provide their food.
That was the daily project,
to provide your food.
I asked once my mother,
"What did you do
when we hadn't anything to eat?"
And she told me, "I told you stories
and I sang to you," which is genius.
Yeah, which is beautiful.
So this play, it's called
"I Killed My Mother."
My titles, you can
see, are very gentle
and very inviting for
everybody, yeah?
This is the La MaMa version in
New York, which was a joy for me,
very well received, [Inaudible]
and Julie [Inaudible].
The other thing which I
would mention here to you
but because this is
important actually for me,
that I'm very interested in
this idea of open dramaturgy
when I'm doing a theater piece.
That means that I don't decide the
number of characters in the play.
I offer a text, a texture
rather than a text, and I offer,
if it's possible, total freedom
for the company, for the director.
Because in the theater,
a text never saves you,
because we can destroy even
a genius Shakespeare text.
Sometimes Hamlet is
boring too, right?
Not the text saves you, but your
courage to get in that story
and to consider your own.
This is a play which is running now
back home in Hungarian language now.
"Juliet" is running now,
both in Romanian language
and Hungarian language in
three different places.
The title of this play
is the following --
be very strong now - It's "Porn."
It's P-O-R-N.
And it's about political
pornography.
What is it mean, political
pornography?
That there are periods in the
history when the politicians want
to own our body, want to
own our intimate life.
What happened to us in '86?
I became officially a
political dissident.
And we noticed the moment when
they bugged our apartment.
We were a very young
couple, with my wife.
And we asked ourselves
now how to make love.
What is [inaudible] and
intimacy of your own life?
After '89, I got from
the Romanian Minister
of Internal Affairs my
secret files, 1300 pages.
And I took these files and
I exhibited all of them.
So when the audience enters
the space of this show,
they go through my files.
We have also photos taken
by the secret police.
Very dear for me in a way because we
are the street, talking to my wife.
And after two kids, she got
pregnant again and she lost her baby
when she was six months
old, but she couldn't abort.
And in the hospital, they
didn't want to intervene,
and we counted backwards the
days, because she was very close
to dying in a septic shock.
So this is what the play is about.
Born is the code name
of this character followed
by the secret police.
My friends are telling me
that why you are giving
so hopeless titles for your play.
Please stop doing that.
I think I told this yesterday.
I remember after the show directed
by Natalia, I told this yesterday
that I don't want to be a merchant
of a cheap hope, because I don't say
around this very easy-going
way to resolve our problems.
So if somebody is not
coming to see my play
because of the title,
that's still fine.
I am fighting successfully
against success.
This is a play which I loved a lot.
It was produced by the Hungarian
National Theater in Transylvania.
The previous one was commissioned
by the Hungarian National Theater
in Budapest to write that play,
and it was performed
in various versions.
This play is called "Alcoholics."
I read an interview with a
woman, an addicted woman,
who told her story in a newspaper.
And the story, it was fascinating.
She's not alcoholic anymore, but
she's telling the way how she went
through this extremely
hard experience.
This is an image of that production.
As you can see again,
it's the same dramaturgy,
only the main character is a real
person and the others are coming
out from her imagination.
And this is humorous and funny
and painful at the same time.
It's a garbage dump there.
And finally, I think this play,
it's called "Caravaggio Terminal."
It's about Caravaggio.
I don't know how many of you are
familiar with this early Baroque,
late Renaissance painter.
He became a very close
friend of mine.
He was a genius and one
of the biggest painters
in this 17th century.
He died in 1610 at a very early age.
I fell in love with him because he
could never integrate in the system.
He got commissions, being genius,
but then the system got
him, went against him.
So he had to leave Rome.
He went to [Inaudible], and he
wanted always to come back to Rome.
I was very interested in the way
how he preserves his freedom.
He got the highest
commissions in Rome.
If you're going to Rome,
Santa Maria del Popolo Church,
you can see his paintings
[inaudible].
I tried to follow his way of being
free, being radical in his messages.
Just one trunk remained
after him at Porto Ercole.
And in spite of getting the
highest commissions in his time,
nothing remained after him.
He gave away all his
money all the time.
So he never became an
established artist.
Sometimes my kids are telling
me that that is the time for you
to become an established artist.
[ Laughter ]
Okay, so now to summarize a
little bit and I will finish here.
What does it mean to be removed
from your space of freedom?
It means the trauma which
creates, for instance,
a very special amnesia for you.
Or it creates -- it's
called also anomia.
Nomos means weird or [inaudible].
So you are an outcast when
rapes your freedom, right?
What does it mean, this?
That means that you forgot
to read the language,
now metaphorically speaking.
We lose the meanings of our words.
What happened after
the Second World War?
The major authors of the
Western culture are speaking
about the impossibility to
use again the same language.
Where to go now?
What is the meaning of this
consensus for everybody, right?
Thou shall not kill?
After, for instance,
Auschwitz when killing kids,
killing mothers in
a professional way.
One of my favorite authors, who
was awarded with a Nobel Prize,
Imre Kertesz, in2002, I knew him
personally, and I even rewrote one
of his novels in three
different versions for the stage.
For a one-man show, 10 actors,
and again for 10 actors.
In his acceptance speech
delivered in Stockholm,
he speaks about this -- that for
him the hardest part of his life
after coming home from
a prison camp was
to reconstruct the language,
to create new meanings.
Who is from this point of
view, my master in the history
of the Western theater
is Samuel Becket.
Samuel Becket, the former
disciple of James Joyce.
You know, a novel of James Joyce,
it's as rich as the
creation, "Ulysses."
And Samuel Becket wanted
to follow the same path.
After [inaudible] that
path got close to him.
It was an abyss, not a road.
And then he [inaudible]
it's a very famous phrase.
It was a mystical turn he names like
this, a mystical turn in his life,
when he says that subtracting
rather than adding.
So he created the very poor
language, almost a known language.
He created of poetry
of the depraved.
So he created the space of
the theater, loop dramaturgy.
What does it mean,
this loop dramaturgy?
The endlessness.
He's going around all the time,
"Waiting for Godot," "Endgame",
his genius radio plays, "Footfalls,"
etc, etc. He is going always around,
always around and tries
to expend the time,
because he doesn't fear the
possibility to go further.
Sometimes in the theater
this is what I am doing.
Don't go further.
Slow down.
Be more radical with yourself.
And if somebody in the
audience would get bored,
this is also part of the event.
I don't want to torture
you now in the theater,
but sometimes it happens.
[ Laughter ]
Because the basic question is always
for a playwright, "What
happened to us?
What happened to me?"
So the drama, the play is a literary
text created with no language
and we can understand it
because of the actors,
only because of the actors.
If they don't offer
totally their lives for us,
we won't understandably the play.
I think that we cannot
understand Hamlet either,
or the very funny Moliere.
So sometimes I direct but very
rarely, and my actors are asking,
"What is your main stage direction."
You need to die on the stage.
Then when we are applauding you, you
need to respect and to smile to us.
Thank you very much.
[ Applause ]
>> Kenneth Nyirady: I think we
have time for a few questions.
>> By any definition, you and
your family were fortunate
by the Communist regime -
emotionally, physically, whatever.
And comes 1989, and the
door of the prison opens.
Why did you decide to stay
in the locale of the vulture?
Why were you not living
in Switzerland
or Denmark or where ever?
>> Andras Visky: I lived
in the United States,
working as a visiting
professor here.
I got many offers to stay
with my family, but I realized
that I don't want to construct
a different identity for myself.
I have my own stories.
I have to tell these stories.
And I think that after '89, both in
Romania and Hungary and that region,
it was a big challenge to
work on an idea of the freedom
or social justice,
especially as a playwright.
I'm considered the first who wrote
plays about the communist past.
And it was a big surprise
for me that nobody wanted
to speak about that past.
So I think that my career or
my journey cannot be described
with these geographical
regions, Switzerland
or this heaven of banks, whatever.
I don't know.
I can't see floating
banks around me.
I think that it's much for me as a
writer, much important to go back
in time and to create pages or
images which tell to my audience
that the most fragile aspects of
the human life is the freedom.
And time to time, we are
ready to give up our freedom.
To invest our freedom in
somebody, to hit him instead
of hitting ourselves by
giving up our freedom.
And also, it's important for a
writer to be surrounded, I think,
if you don't switch
your language by those
who are speaking the same language.
To follow how the language,
the evolution of the language,
the evolution of the meanings, how
language is being changed after '89,
for instance, in our region.
>> How can the political
changes effect you
as person that has [inaudible].
>> Andras Visky: For me, '89
was a big, big, and happy event.
I was vice president of
the county, for instance.
But I realized after a while
that I had to resign to not
to destroy totally this county.
I had to offer the
space for somebody else.
You know how it affected?
For us young professionals,
intellectuals,
university professors, it was the
time to construct things from zero.
Ken mentioned the publishing house.
I'm not doing it anymore.
I worked on creating out of
the blue a theater department
as a part of our University.
[Inaudible] University
is a huge university.
We have almost 60,000 students.
I was very challenged because
of these opportunities,
and then I began to travel
everywhere in the world.
But I realized that in most of
the big democratic countries,
everything is almost done.
I don't want to enter
in something new.
>> And your writings?
How has it affected your writings?
>> Andras Visky: Probably a lot.
I don't know because you don't
have to counter, test for this.
Just let me tell you one aspect.
It took a long time to kill the
inner censorship in your mind,
to don't censor yourself.
You know, because a censorship,
it's both a political aspect
but it becomes a part
of your identity.
So you need to be very
courageous to go against this.
>> It seems like those who
celebrate freedom are those
who have been in captivity.
I sense in your works a
longing to go back to captivity
because of the treasures
and the wonder and the joy
of experiencing the freedom
that came afterwards.
And even in that.
My big question -- is it possible
to find freedom without captivity?
>> Andras Visky: I think
that the captivity,
it's not a simple political term.
It could be a very personal term.
But this is common sense, that
the freedom is not a given thing,
but I think that the
captivity is a given thing.
The structure of -- sorry for that,
but I'm not very optimistic
regarding the human being
in general.
Because I got to see things,
a lot of things around me,
people dying on the street,
in that prison camp also.
Mothers and were unbelievable,
especially the winters.
I still dream is this winter?
I have the sound of the -- For me,
the snowing is not that romantic.
I could see my mother, how
she tries to hide herself
to not be watched, how she cries.
Now, what's next?
I think that the captivity
- Well, I don't you now
to become prisoners today.
I cannot help you.
The captivity in many
ways makes you mature.
I was a child, but I noticed
much, much more than many others.
But in the same time, you know,
also for me the captivity is a
special experience of the body
that sometimes I feel that I
remained in many ways a prisoner,
not having the trust
sometimes in people around me.
That level of trust you
need to continue your life.
>> [Inaudible] and does
this dramaturgy apply
to all of your plays?
>> Andras Visky: I don't know.
Read the book, because there are,
I don't know how many, seven,
eight critical essays
about what I'm doing now.
But you know, barrack dramaturgy, I
consider the theater being a prison.
We entered the prison and
we get out from the prison.
For instance, in one of my plays,
we shot the audience
behind the Iron Curtain.
And it was very meaningful for them
because the Iron Curtain is a
metaphor of the Eastern Bloc,
and the concreteness of the iron.
People were very disturbed
because of that.
Historically speaking, you know?
Because you are a director,
historically speaking,
you know the black box is the
tomb, is the [inaudible] tomb.
You remember the main
[inaudible], 8th,
9th century when the theater
again, after 1000 years of silence.
We hadn't had theater
for 1000 years.
When I say this, I'm speaking
of professional theater.
You know, after the Greek.
The historians say that it was
1000 years without theater.
And then in the 8th, 9th century,
it emerged from the
Catholic liturgy in the West.
I'm speaking about
the Western countries.
So I am telling you this,
that the architecture
of the back box goes
back to the empty tomb.
So what are the actors doing?
They entered the empty tomb.
They are dying as persons.
We see them as characters and they
are coming out from the empty tomb.
It's the same.
I barrack dramaturgy for me,
that's why it is important
because it's very personal,
and at the same time historically
speaking you have a foundation
for it.
>> Kenneth Nyirady:
No more questions?
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at LOC.gov.